a valley mother facing child abuse
charges after police say she left her
three children
home alone in a room with the door duct
taped shut
now the i-team first broke this story
last night terrami beverly arrested in
january metro police saying the children
were trapped in a bedroom and bathroom
area with a bathtub overflowing
police say they found beverly's
one-year-old asleep on the wet floor
now according to her arrest report
beverly told police she'd never done
something like this before
and that she was falling on hard times
and right now
times are tough for a lot of people and
what help is available for parents who
are struggling to raise their kids right
now
orca mana joining us now live with a
look at some of our local resources orco
well and brian it's hard for some
parents to imagine leaving their kids
alone
while they go out into the world and
that's because
those parents are sometimes struggling
but local organizations say
that they are here to help it's really
just a heartbreaking situation
teremi beverly is accused of duct taping
a door shut to keep her three young kids
in a room at home while she went to the
store
according to an arrest report beverly
said she was going through tough times
as a single mother of three
while this may be an extreme case a lot
of people are struggling right now but
for those reaching a breaking point
there is help
we're here to provide them with the
education and the tools that they need
the local charity babies bounty provides
baby bundles to families in need which
includes cribs car seats clothes and
more
plus there's a required class teaches
them how to properly care for a newborn
with safe sleep practices safe water
practices and it also
teaches them how to safely use the items
that we give them other organizations
such as the shade tree and
united way are also great resources
experts with prevent child abuse nevada
say
that support is critical especially if a
parent feels like they need to choose
between caring for their kids
and leaving to go to work or put food on
the table there's just all of these
choices to make day to day that
other people never have to think about
how they're going to make those things
happen
the main message there is help available
our goal is to provide a safe
environment for
children in southern nevada and a lot of
that help is
free we have links to non-profits and
different resources
here in the valley on our website eight
newsnow dot com
reporting live tonight orca mana 8 news
now